let's get going for those of you who
don't know me I have been around
developing code since 1978 as a
developer until comparatively recently
about 10 years ago when I began focusing
more on UX design I still do write code
so I come from that developer
perspective and I understand something
about UX design talking to developers
that I'm not sure that that some
designers really get and that is that
the touchy-feely way a lot of designers
look at a UX design doesn't really work
very well with developers so I talk
about it more from a science background
show examples and this session we'll get
into some of the science behind how
users actually see their user interfaces
so that it's not just somebody's opinion
that it happens and I have tests and
such that will let you see it in your
own mind this becomes progressively more
important because people are used to
dealing with apps like the one over
there on the left but what do they look
what do they look at in their companies
probably something more like what's on
the right and so that user expectations
are starting to rise and we're expected
to do better even in routine business
software understanding what your users
see when they look at a screen is one of
the key foundations of doing good UX
design if you don't really understand
how the users see what you create you're
kind of fumbling around in the dark you
might do a B testing and a works out
better than B but why is they better
than B is there a C that's superior to
either of them that you might know if
you understood something about the
principles so that's why knowing this
stuff is extremely helpful there's a
there's a an example that I'm not going
to do but I will I would urge you to do
it some of you may have seen this it's a
video of two teams passing basketballs
around you've seen this
how many of you have seen that video
yeah but but over a little over half the
audience so I won't do it since less
than that probably have not seen it but
I would I would encourage you to go out
and see it and it will it will really
surprise you I think something about how
you see things but I'm gonna substitute
with that another
test that kind of shows the same thing
I'm going to show some slides I have
three slides and I'm going to show each
one for just a few seconds each and each
slide will have drawings of common
household tools that you might find
around your house or your workshop your
task is how many to count the number of
slots figure out how many slides contain
a hammer you ready I'm only going to
show each slot for just a second or two
okay so how many hammers did you see two
hammers that's fine how many pairs of
scissors did you see he says he saw two
anybody else got a clue about wrenches
did you know there were wrenches
screwdrivers say your brain was primed
to look for what I told you to look for
and it sort of filtered out the rest
that demonstrates a design principle
called inattentional blindness that it's
it's an example of a design principle
that's based on how our eyes see things
how we perceive the world and you can't
really get around it because the bulk of
your users are going to behave in a very
consistent way based on this principle
here's this particular design principle
is based on the way the eye works do you
guys remember biology there was a term
called a fovea does that word mean
anything to you
you probably learn it in biology for a
test and probably promptly forgot it
it's the part of the retina that gives
you high resolution vision it's actually
pretty small it gives you about this
amount of resolution when you hold a
quarter or like this bottle cap hold
that at arm's length that's about how
much the fovea sees it really isn't very
much and what the visual system is doing
is constantly moving that area around to
what it thinks is important and the rest
is pretty much filled in with a
convincing fake you don't
actually see it you don't actually
perceive it because you don't have high
enough resolution to resolve it if we
were if we had a brain and visual system
big enough to perceive our entire visual
system our heads would be the size of a
watermelon it would take that much in
the in the terms of neural mass well
from an evolutionary perspective that
just doesn't make any sense so you
remember that screen I showed you a few
minutes ago you really didn't see it
when I showed it what you really kind of
saw it first
was something about like this when your
eye was looking at cuz you tend to look
at the upper left corner first so some
of you probably saw noticed on that
screen that it was Sherlock Holmes but
you almost certainly did not notice a
lot of the other stuff for instance if
the eye darts over here you see that
there's something about ret rest or
possums well that's obvious gibberish
but did you realize it was gibberish the
first time you saw it most of you may
not have even done that because you
didn't really have anything to direct
you and look around so you only see
small parts of what's on the computer
screen at any particular time that's
just the way your eyes work it's
something we can't get around it's a
reason for example that all those error
messages that people put on status bars
at the bottom or at the top are
pointless
people are not really seeing them so
that's a design principle inattentional
blindness based on the way that the the
brain works because that's I mean you
think that everything is clear because
your eye just keeps moving around but
it's not really your eyes not really
seeing all that and in addition to just
the way that the visual system works as
I said with the the whole example of
what - are you looking for there's this
concept called priming priming means
that you are heavily influenced by what
you expect to see what you see is in a
sense an artifact of what you expect to
see let me show you an example from
earlier in this week actually across the
parking garage across as some of you
probably parked in the parking garage
across the street I was over there
getting some coffee on the other side of
it and I came back into the lowest level
and
came from the stairs to the to the
lowest level to the elevator so I'm
walking up to the elevator now if I'm
walking up to an elevator what do I
expect to see what am I looking for a
button to call that elevator if I'm on
the lowest floor there's probably just
one what shape do I expect it to be
around so I walk up to the elevator from
the stairs and I see this and I walk
right over there and press it and the
security guy comes on it says yes this
is security no I'm sorry I just meant to
call the elevator and you could tell
from this telling a voice this happens
Tim twelve times a day all right this is
a little bit more expansive view there
is an elevator button there and I did
find it but when I walked up I expected
to see a round elevator button so I just
went to the I was coming in from that
that side where the security button was
so I just pressed it and here's the
thing about it the average person will
do that and go oh god I was dumb no I
see I don't understand design and I
don't assume that I'm stupid because I
made a mistake I presume it's bad design
that thing should have been colored red
or something
there are various visual indicators that
would make it and make it a different
shape don't make it look like an
elevator button so that's an example of
priming there's also a a related
principle I'm going to show more
software examples that kind of combine
some of these in a few minutes there's a
there's another related principle called
framing what you see is influenced about
what you expect to see from previous
experiences the frame that you your
mental your your mind is in and this is
based quite a bit on experience so if I
go into a kitchen I expect to see a
stove I mean that's just a part of the
usual setup of a kitchen I expect to
wanted to be there they've done Studies
on this if you set up a kitchen without
a stove in it and you just kind of tour
people through the house and and you and
you get them on out they will remember a
stove being there despite the fact that
it was not there I saw this when I moved
into my own house twenty-something years
ago because the Sun
was sunken and you don't really expect
that right you were framed for houses
that things are kind of the floor is
pretty much level so when we bought my
wife was talking about yes
let's move the let's move the we can
wheel the exercise equipment in and out
from the sunroom to the living room I
know you can't it it's it's a drop-off
there she it is her mind remembered it
as being flat because that's what she
expected and this applies in software
when we start to get people in a
particular in a rhythm of what they
expect so just if you imagine that we've
got four pages in this process and
you've got back in next a certain in a
certain order and then you change it up
on the bottom you're going to confuse
users and they're gonna press the wrong
one I will tell you a story of when I
did that American Airlines had this very
problem in a different a slightly
different form they recently fixed it
but it was up about eighteen months it
very very poor design
so let's thought let's talk about about
how we were doing here this was the
fourth screen in getting myself a flight
on American and all of the prettiest
screens have had a button in the lower
right-hand section that said continue so
I just fill in my stuff up at the top
scroll to the bottom and hit that button
and just throw away everything I just
put on the first three screens now why
did they do that well they were thinking
oh gosh we should always rattle on our
buttons and we shouldn't show buttons
they can't use no see you put those two
together and now you are violating a
design principle because people expect
there to be a continue button right
there in fact I would bet you big money
that there were people that called
American Airlines and said your software
has a bug I hit the continue button
and it threw away everything I'm
guarantee there are people who saw
continue there because that's what they
expected and and people are heavily
heavily influenced by that see the
problem here was that I hadn't filled in
credit card information yet
and until I fill in credit card
information it doesn't show the button
to go forward it at that point it moves
that start over button and then puts the
correct button in its place that's just
bad design folks they did eventually
take that out I can tell you as a based
on my experience in UX design American
Airlines was losing money every day that
was up every day context influence is
what you expect to see also suppose I
tell you you're looking at a campus map
ok the next slides of campus map and you
see roads and you see buildings and such
ok you see that and then I tell you
actually know there's a word if I take
all that other stuff away and tell you
there's a word in there can you see it
did you see it before very few people do
because your visual system was expecting
a map and I told you there would be
buildings on it and so your visual
system saw that and thought ok buildings
cool and then when I told you to expect
something else your visual system
shifted its perception this particular
example plays into what's called
figure-ground it's one of the gestalt
principles we're gonna talk a bit more
about those further on down in the
presentation some of you may have seen
these in science classes or something
gets taught principles have to do with
how the visual system works one set some
German scientists figured this out about
a hundred years ago figure-ground means
that there is a part of our visual field
that our brain decides to pay attention
to it decides that's what's important
and the rest is background but the
perception of it as you saw what the
campus buildings can change your your
brain can switch with what the visual
system considers the figure and what it
considers that considers the ground so
we did that back here and now if we if
the why it becomes the ground now we see
the word if the black is the ground we
see buildings so here this is one of the
famous you may have seen this this
drawing before a very famous figure
ground drawing do you see a laws or do
you see two faces
see two faces is a little more than half
typically and and but now that you know
that they're both you have the ability
to switch what you consider to be the
figure and ground you know Billy what
could that possibly have to do with
software actually you've seen this this
ability to switch figure and ground we
did this in a system we created back in
2008 our first modern UI application we
designed it so that the in this
particular screen the figure is that
data entry screen that you're working on
that maintenance screen for a company
but if you want to enter an address then
you put you pressed it you press one of
the addresses and say you want to edit
or add a new one then it switches it
actually animates to do this so notice
that this thing is going to get smaller
and some gray is going to come over it
and then the new screen appears in front
of it
now that is a tip-off to the visual
system that this is what you need to be
looking at if we didn't gray out and and
do something with that background now it
becomes significantly harder to pick out
the thing they should look at from the
background which looks a whole lot like
it so we can influence what the eye sees
has figure and what it sees is ground
with various tricks like this and a lot
of websites do this now so yeah you go
back after after you finish a lot of
website to do this
so here's Twitter and you know it's just
got all of its usual stuff and then if I
click on a tweet to get information I
get something like this you've seen this
right and then the background Gray's out
and then when I'm finished with that
there's an X up there in the corner that
that lets me go back so fair ground is
very important but you have to
understand the fact that you can switch
it and what you're trying to do to
direct attention if you don't understand
that then the concept of figure-ground
can lead you into the wrong conclusion
about things the visual studio team did
this in 2012
you remember that toolbar that was
washed out and almost no color and it
was really hard to find things a true
story about six months after it was
released I was doing
demo of some WPF stuff and I commented
out some code using a button up there
and I heard a gasp from the audience and
I look to the guy and he said I've been
looking for that button for six months
okay the toolbar was that washed out
here's the here's the really bad news
the way it looked there is the way it
was looked in release but I saw it when
it was rolled out in beta to a group of
MVPs up at Microsoft Visual Studio on
Windows MVPs they rolled it out and had
no color at all why were they doing that
well they thought well what's the figure
the figure is the code window so we want
to focus attention on the code window
well I mean that's fun so far as it goes
but figuring ground can switch based on
what you're trying to do so if the
toolbar is completely washed out and it
never brightens up when the mouse is
over it or anything like that then it
becomes an impediment to people finding
what they want when you've dimmed it
down that much I was there in that
meeting no color in the toolbar and I
think the buttons are too small too but
that's that's another that's another
discussion and these people beat that
team up mercilessly
I didn't say a word I didn't have to it
was such an obvious problem that
everybody else picked up on it and they
did add just a little bit of color now
you compare it to what we have now and
you can kind of see the differences
between the two they've they've learned
to put some color back I still think I
still think the toolbar could be really
improved but but they don't like making
changes because if they screw it up like
they did they get a lot of grief out of
it and if they don't change anything
everybody just goes oh good so there's
danger and change but that's the way you
improve so it's tough you can be primed
by your past experience as kind of an
addition to your expectation I talked to
a bit about this already about sort of
the elevator situation so um not only do
you expect the button you call an
elevator to be round you expect buttons
on elevators to be around to you so you
get on an elevator like this one sort of
Marriott New Orleans and you get on it
you're not paying much attention what
you're doing
you got luggage maybe you got kids or
whatever and you press well a surprising
number
people here are pressing the placards
instead of the button how do I know that
because the G has its paint worn off
people are getting on there and hitting
that placard despite the fact that
especially on the G they've already been
in the elevator who wants to go up to
their rooms this is the second time and
they're still making the mistake so I
mean this this entire elevator panel is
just a train wreck of bad design but I
want to focus in on the idea that I mean
you've got bad alignment and you've got
and that placard is in the middle of a
column of buttons which is even more
misdirection but I yeah I like that's
the the the G there is the reason I went
back got my camera and took this picture
because it's unambiguous evidence of bad
design it's I mean nobody can argue with
me that this is bad design and the the
placards there there various other
problems gonna come back to this
elevator panel a little lighter because
it also has problems with proximity
having to do with the buttons being
equal distant between the placards you
look at the let's say how do you how do
you know which one is the button for for
well you you have to look at the whole
row for that because it's equidistant
between four and five which means you're
imposing additional cognitive load on
whoever gets on this elevator well all
those principles apply to software as
well if things aren't cleanly separated
into groups then it becomes difficult
for the user to parse it out and figure
it out they have to extend expend
additional effort and that usually means
additional time just to show that this
problem is is not he's kind of
ubiquitous this is in Las Vegas at the
signature of very upscale hotel by the
well by the way and it's got exactly the
same problem I was actually on this
elevator staying there and I got on with
a guy and he's next to the panel and he
asked me what for I was on I said 25 and
he point he pressed the button for 24
and then said oh I'm sorry I I said no I
don't worry about it it's bad design let
me explain to you about the design of
I mean we're riding 24 floors I figure
out miles well give them a little mini
lesson right there so that means for
example that when you when you start
looking at data visualizations and such
your experience guides you to a certain
extent as to what you understand if
you're in the propane industry this
makes complete sense to you this looks
like a fuel tank and the color is right
for propane on the other hand if you
have to be working with a client that
has fuel oil then the shape of the tank
is different and the color of the fuel
is different so that tips them off
immediately if you're not in that
industry this doesn't necessarily mean
anything to you but if you're in that
industry those things make perfect sense
so there's a certain there's a context
to people in embedded in people's
experience that influences what they see
and how quickly so I talked a little bit
about the whole buttons too close to it
doesn't stand out from them from the
they are joining placards by the way
there are some good elevator designs and
I'm giving you a home work of of now you
shouldn't notice when you see an
elevator that does it right that groups
the the button close to the placard and
doesn't make the placard round because
if a placards round it's more likely to
be confused with a button so now look at
that but let's talk about some of those
that particularly that principle
particularly about the equidistance it
has to do with another gestalt principle
I already talked about figure-ground
this gestalt principle it's called
proximity so another true story iya I
was at a hotel and Amarillo Texas got
off the elevator with all my luggage and
saw this sign and I'm in room 207 so I
start walking that way and get two doors
down and realize I'm gone the wrong way
and go back and see the entire sign you
see I should have gone the other way but
for the range in which my room number is
two a one two two two three
which arrow is closer the one beneath it
so the unnaturally groups things that
are close together and assumes they are
related remember you don't see it all
you only see what you you think you need
to look at so I just wanted to find out
where 207 was I don't care where all the
other rooms are so that led me to go the
wrong way
this sign would be fine if those arrows
would just be moved down two or three
inches because then they would be
grouped with their description and
number ranges properly science software
you see this mistake made by people like
Amazon and I here I'm telling you my own
mistakes because as I said I don't
assume that I'm stupid when I make a
mistake I assume that the person
designing the software or the or the
object just just is not tuned in to good
design so here I'm it's one of those
deal of the day's pages and I go old man
128 gigabytes USB 3 I travel a lot I
need storage this is like 2 or 3 years
ago it's not as big a deal now but then
that was a good deal so I I want to
check one of those there's another
button to put things in the shopping
cart you can check as many as you want
so I can't go right down below it I
checked that thing and go down and check
the button and go over a shopping cart
and my USB thing is not there have you
spotted why not the correct checkmark
for that item is the one that's further
away above it but my eye isn't looking
for that the one that's closest to the
description of the thing I'm getting is
below it so they're there yet and even
people like Amazon do it see it's top
principles like proximity and
figure-ground come out of this structure
of the human visual system and the way
it sees things
there's proximity come at figure-ground
we've also got similarity coming fake
continuity I'll briefly look at all of
those because they're all pretty
important they all are based on
the way the visual system works which is
the first thing that happens is the
retina does some tuning and optimization
of the information to accentuate edges
for example that's stage one in stage
two the the stuff that the retina is
seeing is assembled by the nervous
system by the optic nerve actually some
of that processing happens in the optic
nerve and some of that happens at the
beginning of the visual cortex so that
shapes are kind of assembled into groups
and lines are assembled into shapes and
that is unconscious and it happens very
quickly
as in a fraction of a second and then
you impose your experience upon it to
understand more meaning about the shape
or the group so Gestalt comes out of
stage two for the most part so this is
unconscious it takes place before
conscious interpretation and you can
change those interpret perceptions as
we've seen in figure-ground but that
takes additional cognitive work so you
stop proximity is one of those that
things are a group together are assumed
to be related there's also the issue
that if you get if you make things too
close together
you also have problems with people
inadvertently hitting the wrong thing
and kind of their imprecise way of doing
things especially on mobile apps I
actually worked on a some videos for a
system that it was an it was a mobile
app designer and it had the same thing
what we would call code behind you put
JavaScript and code behind and that's in
the edit buttons where you put it there
but there were some things that you
could run and get a whole bunch of code
pumped in there automatically and if the
thing on the side is blue that means
that you've got some of that code in
there but that button where the blink is
meant I want to wipe out all the code
behind that's in this event and first of
all the iconography is awful and
secondly there was no confirmation so if
I'm going for the edit button but I'm in
a hurry and I slip a little bit over to
the side I can accidentally wipe out an
hour's work just like that and there's
no way to get it back now I graft about
this and they did eventually put up
confirmation a confirmation dialog which
we were talking about later but
that was that was at best a brute-force
fix this should have been better
designed from a layout etc perspective
right there's the edit button I was
talking about and there is the thing
that watch that all previous work I
couldn't believe the design when I saw
that so uh as I said do I have this this
again oh oh I'm sorry I think I think I
moved those slides and left left them in
the old place - oh no I'll put it here
because there were others some other
principles in addition to you stop that
what that were violated consistency in
symmetry and alignment that that that
elevator also had those principles
violated as well but in this session I
have time to go into a lot of the detail
there so sorry
proximity principle I thought I moved
those but I guess I just copied them the
proximity principle that works inside
your mind and I'm going to show that to
you I'm gonna show you a diagram of
stars four pointed stars and it's going
to be just an array of them and I need
for you to immediately sort of just say
out loud what you see whether you see
rows of stars or columns of stars ready
rows or columns yeah okay everybody
twenty sees in rows or columns you see
columns now despite the fact it's the
same size array and the stars are
identical the only thing that changes is
the spacing but the spacing is enough to
cause your brain to change what it
thinks which items it thinks are grouped
together well turns out the proximity is
not the only thing that causes your
visual system to group you see rows or
columns now now most people see rows
kind depends on their sensitivity color
but most people see rows now despite the
fact that this is the same as what I
just showed you the only difference is
that now some of the stars are colored
so that helps you
see that color causes the visual system
to automatically group so that something
like this can can be grouped differently
that the stop principle is called
similarity that the visual system will
group things that are similar to one
another in size or color or shape size
isn't very strong for that but color and
shape are very strong and causing
grouping so you saw the the rows that
you get here let's look at the next one
you see rows or columns in this and it's
the shapes that are doing it the
similarity of shapes is causing your
visual system see it that way and these
consult principles have been used a long
time and things like charting so
proximity helps you know that this is a
a period all these things are happening
the same time whereas similarity by
color helps you follow a category across
the time range of times so Gestalt has
been used for a while but I think most
developers aren't aren't as aware of it
as they should be and and the gestalt
principles are that sort of the inverse
of the similarity is that you can make
things stand out very easily if I tell
you to find the triangle here you don't
do it you don't expend any cognitive
effort to do that your visual system
does that for you automatically if I
tell you to find the green star again it
happens automatically so you respecting
these principles will give you better
interfaces violating them will induce
people to either be confused or have
errors and as I said good companies do
this all the time this is the Southwest
mobile app I think as it exists today
and I installed it on my new iphone a
couple weeks ago and and now you know
I've got my boarding pass and I'm
looking at that thing if they're saved
to phone GPA
well first of all is that one button or
two and secondly what does GPA have to
do with say my mind assumes there's a
relationship there because of the
proximity and because of the grouping my
Monda so if I save the phone am I going
to pay something to G to Google I mean I
that's a legitimately realistic
perception for a user to have
just because they group that together
and I think I don't understand that at
all I mean there's I can give you four
or five different ways assuming that I'm
right and it really is two separate
buttons I can give you four or five
better designs in ten minutes
and yet whoever's doing the apps from
Southwest just screwed up and didn't
respect a basic principle concerning how
the visual system works the eye also
tends to follow things to completion
that's called Gestalt continuity you
begin to track things it will go in the
same direction until until it changes to
something else and if you violate
continuity that allows you to draw the
eyes attention to things so that for
example if you've got a timeline of
things that offset is seen instantly by
the visual system you again you don't
have to work at it
and can you figure out just from from
looking at this why it's offset it
overlaps with another item so we use
that capability of the visual system I
mean look we could have put that we
could just line them all up and wouldn't
that have been consistent and the
alignment would have been so pretty and
we could have put overlaps with previous
item s and text in there functionally
speaking that works but it doesn't
leverage the user's visual system to
figure it out fast enough they would
tend to overlook that sort of thing
until they had to look at it a long time
and learn okay you guys having fun with
this this interesting stuff you haven't
asked any questions yet
everybody's going yeah well you know
just select watching the Discovery
Channel Billy
you don't ask the guy questions on the
screen you just sort of let him go on to
the next thing
I'm sorry is it normal to see grids
instead of rows or columns well if they
get kind of close enough together it's
normal and and people vary in terms of
how much separation it takes to start to
see rows or columns so there are people
that it takes more separation to see
rows and columns the effect is pretty
much in everybody but it varies in terms
of how much separation you need to
trigger it confused about where I am
they said because I did some changes to
this oh yeah okay
yeah all right all right let's bring
some of this stuff together I want to I
want to show you an example we're gonna
bring some stuff together some of these
principles and and talk a little bit
about leveraging them in a fudged up
software example so this is going to be
kind of harkening back to the
inattentional blindness thing okay so
I'm gonna show you a screen with car a
card view of sports equipment and it's
got you know the description and it's
got the price it's got a little symbol
for what kind of sports quite a little
graphic for what kind of sports
equipment it is and I'm going to leave
it up for about four seconds and I want
you to tell me how many footballs you
find in that card view I think it's
about three or four rows and five or six
each you ready oh yeah six six seven
across three down okay
find those footballs
you see three footballs sometimes that's
not quite enough time I only see two
because it's kind of it's a jumble it's
a jumble on purpose to show this example
okay that's fine but you see how many
baseballs did you see or basketballs
tennis ball soccer ball see again it's
just an example of your I didn't take in
that because your goal directed purpose
your task was to figure out footballs so
that's partially inattentional blindness
but there's lots of interesting ways to
get around it and they have to do with
them with various design principles so
there's a design principle that says
that the size and position of things in
the real world if they are reflected in
a software interface people will
understand the kind of the information
more quickly so if I change the size of
those sports equipment items to more
closely reflect their real-world size
now is it easier to find the baseballs
than it was yeah see that is that helps
you but you're leveraging the visual
system you can almost think of that
visual system as sort of the GPU for
your brain you know do you remember
those old computers that did rendering
on the motherboard and they were just
really slow and you get a good GPU and
now you've got capabilities for doing
graphics and visuals much much more
quickly well that's the part of your
brain that kind of corresponds to that
so if you're doing something on your
computer that is that needs the GPU you
kind of make sure that it uses the GPU
don't you you don't kind of route around
it well that's what you're effectively
doing when you put information in front
of people that ought to be processed by
the visual system but you're making them
do it with cognitive means instead and
the worst design pattern to make people
do that is a data grid because the data
grid for the most part is just text in
numbers some people put a little bit of
colorization in there but very rarely is
that data grid enhanced with the ability
for people to actually see things with
their visual system instead of parsing
it out with their conscious
system alright so but we've got more
design principles we could use for this
we know that we know that things close
together or visually grouped we
discovered that and gets tall proximity
we know that we can group things by
color color helps grouping well why
don't we put all that together and now
do a sports card thing it's like this I
mean compare these two and you tell me
which one you think a user would rather
use on a daily basis and none of this is
really that hard from a development
perspective it's just that his
developers just like okay stick a day to
go down there okay I guess we can sort
it but we're not going to do all these
other interesting things to help people
see the information in front of them
well actually you can actually see this
in them I have is it this one yeah no
it's this one that I've got all that you
can have this example if you want that
I've got all the different ways so you
can use size oh this one's also got
color in the equipment as an interesting
alternative to help people find things
and then that background plus grouping
can let you see it all so that's that's
that's the original program I wrote to
get those screenshots we back this in a
minute
also as you might expect because this is
kind of the way things work in the world
bigger things are assumed to be more
important in some fashion
I mean if I've got if I'm looking at
carrots I want big ones if I'm looking
apples I want to choose the big one
that's got the most nutrition etc so
there's a certain built-in tendency in
the brain to assume that bigger things
are more important and there's also of
course the fact that that just it's
easier to see them because they're
bigger so the visual system tends to key
in on them that gets us into ideas of
information importance that bigger makes
it more important and color can be used
to make important things stand out as
well one of the reasons that that you
don't want your apps basic styling to be
too colorful you prefer to have it kind
of subtle colors fairly muted colors is
that to make things stand out with color
it's a lot easier to do that if the base
styling is fairly subtle and again
you've got to do is look at that Windows
8 Start screen or even this to realize
that companies get it wrong those colors
are considerably muted down from what
Windows 8 was but do you remember eight
with all the Power Ranger colors
when does eight which it was horrible
nothing then stood out because
everything was just too colorful so you
want your base styling to have a certain
amount of subtlety to it and that allows
you to then apply color and make things
stand out that are important so we saw
that with the tanks we saw earlier that
with the green and the red tanks we see
that but also notice that this customer
is a deadbeat and that CEO day really
stands out because it comes out against
the base color scheme which is just sort
of a dark bluish gray also notice that
the most important information about
this customer is right along the top in
a bigger size than the the routine text
remember that screen I showed you at the
very beginning the one that's got
gibberish on it did you how many of you
sort of did that look like a screen
you've seen before in some business app
yeah it's kind of well did you notice
something about that screen everything
that was the same size every piece of
text in it was the same size and that
was what people fell into as a pattern
with the tools of the 90s and early the
early this century that they don't
developers don't tend to think about the
fact that things ought the size ought to
have something to do with importance now
you don't want to have sizes varying all
over the place but here the fact that
it's been 17 days since the last
delivery that's extraordinarily easy to
find we know exactly what their balance
is we know whether or not they're
satisfied with our service with that
little graphic over there the little
smiley face the brain is optimized to
see things like that we could put a
satisfaction index on 47 up there or
something like that but again that would
take cognitive effort for people to
figure out so how we arrange the
information and and let the users see it
has a pretty dramatic effect on their
performance so let's say we've got some
information about interactions with a
customer and there they are we've got
eight interactions with that customer in
a data grid and and if I stare at that
data grid long enough I could probably
figure out anything I need but why would
we want people to spend their time
staring at data grids well we can
enhance the data grid we could put some
shapes in there to help them figure out
what the payments versus the service
items are or we could maybe make the
amounts of bigger if we wanted to but
really with modern technologies we can
we can custom design how we want that
information to show with different sizes
for different things but we can do
better than that suppose I'll put them
on a timeline instead now notice that
group at the top the proximity principle
will tip off our brains that those four
things that are over
laughing are probably related in some
fashion that maybe there and sure enough
we look at it we go okay yeah there's a
there's a service call there for $2,000
and oh we had to go back because
somebody messed up and there's a leak
that that needed to be fixed and then
they came in and paid most of it and
then came back and paid some more later
you say you know the user doesn't really
have to to think about it to realize
those things are probably related in
some fashion they might not be but
because you know sometimes things happen
at the same time do the coincidence but
there's certainly a possibility that
they're related so if we put them on a
time line we are leveraging the visual
system to help people see that they are
related very quickly all right you guys
don't okay some of you like
shell-shocked here it's like yes right
there
yes
Oh II okay well let me put it this way
the visual principles always apply
because that's where the visual system
works so if I've gotten very complex
data that raises the bar for me to find
a way to express it in a way that they
assimilate it quickly simply dumping a
lot of data if people is almost never
the right way to do it there are a few
limited exceptions to that but in
general the more complex the data is the
more I want to be able to leverage these
principles to help people understand it
because the speed-up will be better now
if I've got really complex things I
might have to be able to switch what's
important so I've got the ability to
change the visualization depending on
what it is they're trying to do to call
out different things as being important
but I'm still going to give them as much
help as I can to leverage the visual
system to help them find out what they
want to find out very quickly did that
and and I think one of the things you
might be hitting at is that if you go to
certain kinds of users engineers would
be typical that they just kind of want
you to dump everything in front of them
and let them figure it out which let
them figure it out and the reason they
want you to do that is they don't trust
you to do a better job than they would
do themselves they don't trust you to
understand how they look at that
information enough to come up with
better ways they just don't think you
can do it so they will ask you just dump
it all out and I'll figure it out
because to them the alternative is you
hide things that they can't find or or
you put it in such a way that it's
harder to understand so in many cases
that's that's where that tendency comes
from to just dump it all out there is
that the users may ask for it but that's
because they haven't seen anything
better and as an industry we do a pretty
job of so a pretty poor job of showing
them things that are better
so yeah you can you can give him a data
grid or you can give him a list box or
maybe you go you know going all the way
up to a time line now these principles
as as almost anything about people's
consciousness can can be done can be
subverted using these principles you can
hide things you don't want people to
look at direct their attention to what
you want to go right past something that
you don't want them to see doing that I
mean let me put this in as stronger
terms as I can
doing that is unethical and I don't
think you should work for any company
that tells you or forces you to do that
and I'm talking about some pretty big
companies here this is this is the goo
from the Google App Store and we don't
the contrast here is set a little bit
high so it's not quite as easy to see as
it should be but when you when you see
this on a computer monitor that gray
background around the the this this app
has access to it's it's it's more grey
and it's harder to read the text on a
typical computer monitor now let me
first of all point out the fact that the
Hilton app has no business looking at my
context all right there is no excuse for
them to look at my contacts it's a
potential security breach they probably
use some framework that came in and just
set that as a as a default and and
lazily didn't do anything about it so
they shouldn't have put that stuff in
there in the first place but notice that
what the Google App Store does is notice
that big old green install button down
there they don't really want you looking
at that so I put above the blue arrows
by the way of mine they don't really
want you looking at the app permissions
they just want you to install the app
and whether or not the permissions are
appropriate I'm gonna be honest with you
Google doesn't care at this point anyway
so that that app screen leads you to
just go ahead and install an app and
just let your ID gloss right over what
what the what the app has permissions to
City
Bank really wants me to go paperless now
being the paranoid type and knowing that
can always get my statements PDFs online
when I want to I still take the paper
and I throw it in the box
I don't know seed bank servers not
getting nuked for all I know so I guess
I'll have bigger problems I guess than
finding my city bank statement in that
case but but I still want the paper and
so look guys for seed bank cards 1984 so
I've been dealing with this a long time
but they've gotten more aggressive about
it lately
yes papers go paperless look here and so
they've got two things to bottom accept
or manage settings
what's manage settings gonna do I don't
know I'm afraid that what it's going to
do is make me do paperless that there
won't be an option not to if I go there
see I have no idea but I don't trust
them because I don't trust big software
companies and big institutions in
general and so now I'm looking I just
want to go to my accounts
I don't what do I do how do I get to my
accounts well some messing around and
seeing etc if I if I press the little
city icon up there I will go where I
want to go to my accounts but they
shouldn't make it hard for me to find
that that doesn't look like a button
they don't want me pressing that even
though that is exactly what I need to
press to do what I want to do and also
we don't see this much anymore but a few
years back remember when you would put
Adobe Flash Player on anybody remember
this screen notice that this looks
pretty much like the terms and
conditions over there it's just like oh
yeah you don't need to read this just
just go ahead and install fortunately
that that stuff's about going other
other principles that affect what users
tend to see we've talked something about
from about experience but familiarity is
a part of that also there's an idea of
archetypes
we we almost saw that with the elevator
situation that what shape do of a in
general culturally speaking the shape of
an elevator button is typically round
that's almost an archetype that an
expected form that's almost universal
well what is the expected shape of a
button in computer software rectangular
probably with some color of gradient
behind it that stands out from the
foreground that's that's kind of what we
think a button is so I'm gonna kind of
well that was a Marriott how does a
Marriott Courtyard in in Pennsylvania
trying to get on the wireless it's about
three years ago they've changed this
since then I mean we are seeing designs
start to do better some of these
companies are getting people who have a
clue but but it's a fairly recent thing
and so I get on and I see this like oh
yeah high-speed Internet that's what I
want it's free so a press the thing that
says high-speed Internet because looks
like button he's not a button it's a
toddle and if I scroll down far enough I
see yeah there's a button that looks
just like it that should just beneath
for where my screen cut off see that's
just poor design it leads people into
making bed it's frustrating punching
this thing we can't get a button so
that's that's kind of the idea of the
elevators that we've got the roundel up
they look like buttons they're
equidistant just violates those
principles and intends to make people
make mistakes
oh I already did this one didn't I yeah
already did the American Airlines one
yeah sorry again I think I copied those
slides and then didn't didn't cut them
from where they were
I touched a little bit on this idea of
mapping earlier where are the sizes of
the sports equipment should correspond
the real-world sizes the whole principle
of mapping is actually much bigger than
that the VIN the visual system sees
things in a certain way and if you
leverage that you're gonna you're gonna
get perception correct and if you don't
you may get it incorrect so so this uh
let's see yeah this these are diagrams
showing the last two gas ranges that
I've worked with now I don't move very
much the first one was eight years back
from the late 80s the early 90s and then
I moved in my current house and got the
the other I'm sorry that's still what
the one on the the left is my current
range the one on the right is the one I
used for eight years back in the late
80s and early 90s gas ranges now and
this I'm not exaggerating the slightest
one tell you that the eight years that I
used that one I never once turned on the
wrong burner not a single time the last
time I turned on a wrong burner that one
over the in my current house was about
three months ago and I've been living in
that house with that range for 26 years
what's the difference yeah you've got
you know the difference don't you this
is what the control knobs look like in
my current stove my current range at
least they kind of separate the oven but
how do I know what knob goes to what
burner well I kind of hope the two on
the left go to the left burners than two
on the right are the right burners but
which is which I don't know but the old
range had an arrangement knob
arrangement that looked like this the
visual system sees those burners in
perspective and that simulates that
perspective so that the mapping from
knob to burner is unconscious and
virtually instantaneous given the fact
that turning on the knob the wrong
burner could have serious safety
implications I would think that every
manufacturer every range manufacturer in
the world
bring my like that because the range
that I had was made back in the 60s and
yet go looking for ranges good to go
down to Home Depot Lowe's looking for a
range that looks like that some of the
very high-end expensive ones do but but
you won't find many so bad design is
just everywhere but mapping in software
is helps us with things like that the
the timeline is an example of mapping
that when we put things on a timeline
we're mapping them mentally to a place
in time that corresponds to their
physical position and that helps the
mind understand the relationship between
the items and where they map so that's
an example of mapping and in software
you also this doesn't happen quite as
often but context sets expectation for
perception so if I say fold napkins
polish silverware wash dishes but then I
use a similar word French napkins polish
silverware so your brain just
automatically shifts sometimes on
context so you need to be aware of that
that context can set the expectation
structure can tip off perception so if I
show you this number what does it mean
to you probably nothing but if I do it
like this it's pretty obvious what it is
this one any guesses yeah
credit card but see if I do it like that
it's it's obvious and clear how many
places actually put the spaces in the
credit card number when you enter them
or look at them a distressingly small
number distressingly small percentage
even though it's much much easier for
the mind to pick up and understand that
that that there because our visual
system is just tuned to filter it out if
it's if it looks like gibberish stones
on a beach waves in the ocean we tune
things out that we don't think matter so
that if it's just a long string of
digits that looks like gibberish to us
we turn it out that screen with all the
gibberish on it had Sherlock Holmes in
the corner but the rest
gibberish our brains just tuned that
gibberish right out and you know I
probably should explain this to you
I think of software developers is kind
of a tribe of people because we like to
congregate with each other and other
people don't understand this very well
do they we have kind of our own culture
I'm not really part of the tribe I'm
more like an anthropologist observing
the tribe so I don't like see family
languages much and one of the reasons
was they have too much it's kind of
clutter in what looks like gibberish to
me from which this cartoon comes I don't
understand why everybody thinks having
all those different delimiter is that
condom more or less sort of look alike
it to me it imposes additional cognitive
load I think there are other languages
that don't do that I prefer but then the
the community as a whole is sort of
decided on that and my vote doesn't
matter anymore
you can use you can you can impose some
structure with hierarchies particularly
in text so if I put this on a website
you must plot data location and a number
of people in your party finally you need
okay great I mean that does the job I
guess but supposed to do it like this
which one of those is a user going to
perceive and act on correctly faster and
more and more often so we can do things
with with structure to to help people
proceed it oh wow that was second I
thought that was the same thing yeah and
and then we can do visual hierarchies we
can we can use some of the separation to
help people sort of see things as groups
in hierarchies and look here's the
visual studio color picker and to me
transparency translucency of the code
the Alpha Channel is a fundamentally
different thing than RGB so if I'm
designing this screen I'm moving it down
to help understand that it operates in
two you can tell it operates differently
it's not even a number from 1 to 55 0 to
255 like the others it's a
centage although I think it probably
should be I use Siri 255 but anyway the
the separation there helps you
understand that it that it's that it is
in a different family and the final
point I wanna make in the session today
is that you design expecting your users
to be distracted so some of these things
are fairly subtle differences in terms
of how they perceive but they start to
kick in at the margin when people get
distracted and people are people get
distracted as a part of daily life all
the time so your design should be
resistant to distraction unlike let's
say this one which is the one that Steve
Harvey made the mistake of announcing
the wrongness universe now if you stare
at that thing long enough it's not that
hard to figure out what should happen
but think about poor Steve Harvey he's
up there with bright lights in his eyes
he's got a you know an earpiece in there
was somebody babbling at him offstage
about what he needs to do he doesn't
mean he can't just sit there and stare
at the card for 30 seconds to make sure
he's got it right or even 15 he needs to
glance and get it and he glanced and got
it wrong but it wasn't his fault as far
as I'm concerned this was the famous
Hawaii nuclear drill remember that one
well this could use some text hierarchy
some kind of hierarchical structure to
help them not do that right I mean
everything is just all the same not very
well phrased either so you designed for
distractions so that people can do a
better job of using your software error
free okay um we don't have any time for
we're out of time arm Lee I was going to
have time for questions but it looks
like I went over just a bit I'll be
checking my stuff down getting out here
or we got lunch coming up don't we okay
good then I don't have to be in a hurry
anybody who would like to have asked me
some questions before lunch please come
up I have business cards of course for
anybody who might might be interested in
having your team sort of get a little
bit more focused on UX design we're
having some help in designing UX then
myself and I have people who do that so
up come up feel like a business card or
if you have any particular questions I
hope I hope this has been a little bit
fun on the last day of the conference
not so code centric
but you give that part of your brain a
rest thank you folks